LeBRON IS THE LEADING OVERALL
VOTE GIRT WILL DRAFT FIRST.
HE AND KEVIN WILL ALTERNATE
CHOOSING FIRST FROM THE
STARTERS.
NINE GUYS TO CHOOSE FROM RATHER
THAN EIGHT.
AFTER LeBRON'S FOURTH PICK THE
LAST TWO PLAYERS WILL GO TO TEAM
DURANT AND KEVIN WILL HAVE THE
FIRST PICK OF THE RESERVES.
SO WELCOME BLACK AND WE ARE
READY TO GO.
LeBRON, GET US STARTED WITH THE
FIRST PICK.
>> WELL, I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
WELCOMING ME BLACK.
SO WITH MY FIRST PICK IN THE
2022 NBA ALL-STAR GAME, I'M
GOING TO GO WITH THE HARDEST
PLAYING PLAYER IN ALL-STAR
HISTORY, GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO.
>> SIX STRAIGHT ALL-STAR
APPEARANCES AND HE IS NUMBER TWO
IN THE LEAGUE SCORING 29 POINTS
A GAME, 11 REBOUNDS, SIX
ASSISTS.
GIANNIS IS THE FIRST PICK.
K.D., YOU'RE UP.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH LEADING
SCORER IN THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW,
JOEL EMBIID.
>> OKAY.
>> 29 A NIGHT, 11 REBOUNDS ALSO
FOR PHILADELPHIA.
32-22 AND NUMBER FIVE IN THE
EAST AS WE SPEAK.
ALL RIGHT.
LeBRON?
>> WITH MY SECOND PICK IN THE
2022 DRAFT, I'M GOING TO GO WITH
THE GREATEST SHOOTER IN NBA
HISTORY, STEPH CURRY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> CAN'T BE MAD AT THOSE TWO
PICKS.
>> YOU CAN'T GO WRONG WITH A LOT
OF PICKS HERE.
>> THOSE TOP THREE GUYS WILL BE
PRETTY DAMN HARD TO GUARD.
>> KEVIN DURANT, YOU'RE UP.
>> THIS IS HIS DEBUT OUT THERE
IN CLEVELAND IN AN ALL-STAR
GAME, THEY WANT ALL OF THE SMOKE
OUT THERE IN MEMPHIS.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH JA MORANT.
>> AT THE AGE OF 22 AND IN HIS
FIRST ALL-STAR GAME, NUMBER SIX
IN THE LEAGUE IN SCORING WITH 26
A NIGHT.
>> HE CLIMB UP CHIMNEYS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LeBRON?
>> WITH MY THIRD PICK, I'M GOING
TO GO WITH ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS IN THE NBA, DEMARCH --
DeMAR DeROZAN.
>> HE IS HAVING AN INCREDIBLE
YEAR THIS YEAR.
>> 27 A NIGHT AND 17 GAMES OF AT
LEAST 30, INCLUDING THE LAST
FOUR IN WHICH HE HAS PLAYED.
KEVIN?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH MY
FELLOW OLYMPIAN, JAYSON TATUM.
>> GOOD PICK.
GOOD PICK.
>> JAYSON TATUM, OF COURSE, INTO
THE STARTING POOL BECAUSE OF THE
INJURY TO K.D.
K.D., BEFORE WE GET TO THE
LAST -- I MEAN, CAN YOU TELL US
HOW YOU'RE FEELING AND WHERE YOU
ARE IN TERMS OF COMING BACK TO
PLAY?
>> NO.
>> I DIDN'T THINK SO.
BUT I HAD TO ASK.
>> OKAY.
LeBRON?
WITH MY NEXT PICK, I'M GOING TO
TAKE THE WILDCARD, THE JOKER.
>> EIGHTH IF IN SCORING AND
SECOND IN REBOUNDS AND EIGHT IN
ASSISTS FOR THE REIGNING MVP.
THAT MEANS THE LAST TWO PLAYERS,
BOTH GO TO KEVIN DURANT, SO YOU
GET TRAE YOUNG AND YOU